最近はじめんにリプ届かなくて悲しみっ
フッ！
届いてるよ～～～～！！
届いてるんですけど、ごめんねあのぉ
返す時間がない時とかもあるんで
ちゃんと、皆さん見てるからね～
こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーです！
皆さん、スマホに液晶フィルム貼ってますか？
多分、大抵の人は貼ってると思います
落とすと割れちゃうもんねぇ
割れちゃうし、指紋とか付くと嫌だし、なんか
手の滑りが悪い時にこう
滑りやすいスマホの液晶フィルムを使ったりする人がいると思うんですけどもぉ
フンッ！
（ドンッ）
何枚あるんだろう？何枚あるんだろう？
いち、に、
（数え中…）
さんじゅきゅ、よんじゅ、あっ、分かんなくなっちゃった！
きゅうじゅなな、きゅうじゅはち、きゅうじきゅあー
うんこでた～
猛烈な下痢
水下痢ヒャクマーイ！！ こちら！！
マックスむらいのアンチグレアフィルム、iPhone 6 Plus
参ります。えぇ１０００円ですね
待ってこれ１０００円ってことは、１００枚だとぉ、１０００×１００で
十万円ッッッ！
（効果音：デンッ！）
ムライさんから頂きました
ありがとうございますっ！！
バンッッ！
僕これちょっとやってみたかったんですけど
このスマホの液晶フィルムにぃ
１０万円とか出すのは「ホントにマジでネェワ」と思ってて
出さなかったんですけども
ムライさんから貰いました
ワァイ！！
これ、凄いのがですね
滑りを強化するっつって
メチャクチャ滑るんですよね
このフィルムが
でもこれは、iPhone 6 Plusで古いから
もう多分売れなくなったのかなっていう
予想はしているですけど
これが「アンチグレアフィルム」です
メチャクチャ滑りが良くて
なんかパズドラとかで
こうスルスルスルッってできるっていのをよく言われているんですけども
スゥ、滑るといえば！
僕です
今回このアンチグレアフィルムを１００枚使って
最高に滑る床を作ってみようと思いますぅ
（だんだん小声に）
ユーリオンアイス
フィギアスケートができるようなフィールドをね
廊下に展開できれば一番僕的に嬉しいんで
うわっ！すごい
このムライさんの「アンチグレアフィルム」を使って
床を全て「アンチグレア状態」に仕上げ
地上最高に滑る床を作っていこうと思います！
では!
貼ります
わっあ、ヤバイこれっ！！
あっ、滑る滑る滑る全然滑る
使わせていただきます
わー凄い、マジで滑るなコレ
わー、あー、凄い凄い凄い！
完成しましたぁ!(パチパチパチパチパチパチ)
いやぁ、なかなか凄いっスよ
アッアッ、ビックリした！！
ビックリしたぁ
今、心霊現象起きましたからね
凄い貼り心地だぁっ
はいっ、と言うわけで全部貼ったんですけどもぉ
凄い滑ります
これ多分スマホに貼ると凄い触りやすいんだなってくらい滑ります
もうね、ホント
音が凄いのね
ていうのは、１００枚分ここに貼りましたぁ
で、これ多分なんですけど、あのぉ
それでもなんか、ビュンビュン滑るわけでもないっすね
ちょっと滑るくらいっすね
手の指で滑りやすいように作られてるのが「アンチグレアフィルム」なんで
(タンタンッ)
足の指は無理っスね
iPad proとか滑んねぇかなぁ
あ～滑る滑る！
滑るものがすげぇ特定されてんなぁ
まぁでも間違いなくiPad proはすごい滑りますね
あぁやばいやばいやばい
間違いなくiPad proはすごい滑ります
フライパン
はぁっ！はぁっ！
ん～…
あぁやっぱiPad proが一番滑りますね
鏡とか？
(ﾄﾞﾝｯ）
逆にこういうクッションとかだったら滑る気がするんだよな
うぅ…
だって人だと絶対滑んないんだもん
３，２，１
思ったより人で滑るな
あ、全然！思ったより人でも滑れる！
これ背中とか使ったら滑れるかもしれません！
やってみましょう！
では行きます！
３，２，１！
ｱ"ｱ"ｱ"ｱ"ｱ"!!!
（エンディング）
ふとした時に会いたくなるよ♪
トゥ…誰と居ても会いたくなるよ♪
パパパパパ♪